[Música]
en France 24 es momento de doblar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión vamos a
iniciar en Estados Unidos para nadie es
un secreto que Google tiene El dominio
al hablar de motores de búsqueda Así ha
sido al menos durante dos décadas pues
la compañía Microsoft quiere dar un
salto revolucionario y va a incluir en
su motor de búsqueda Bing una tecnología
de Inteligencia artificial se trata de
una versión alterna del buscador que
contará con la Inteligencia artificial
de la compañía openiyey famosa por ser
la creadora de chat gpt o chat gpt este
chatbot que ha sido sensación por el
amplio número de tareas que realiza y
porque imita el lenguaje humano de forma
muy realista
es un nuevo día para las búsquedas es un
nuevo paradigma vendrá una rápida
Innovación de hecho inicia una carrera
en términos de lo que podrían esperar
vamos a movernos a movernos rápido
things cada día queremos traerles mucha
diversión e Innovación en búsquedas
entre los atributos de la Inteligencia
artificial de Bing está que es capaz de
citar la Fuente donde proviene la
información algo que el chat gpt no hace
y ofrece datos que no están en internet
además puedes hacer comparaciones
detalladas e incluso da consejos y se lo
piden está diseñada para hacer lo que
llamamos políticamente correcta y como
ya lo mencionábamos la compañía dice que
será Revolucionaria justamente por la
capacidad de esa Inteligencia artificial
de masterizar la forma de comunicación
huma esto porque trabaja con una red
neuronal profunda y un algoritmo de
aprendizaje automático lo que significa
que al nutrir su base con libros
manuales de instrucciones periódicos y
otros escritos imita de forma altamente
realista la comunicación humana
creemos que hay dos cosas emergiendo
Una es los agentes de inteligencia
conversacional Creo que será algo que
tendremos a donde vayamos interacción
con computadores y será medida con un
agente que ayude
de hecho tendremos esta noción de un
copiloto que estará presente en cada
aplicación dentro del sistema operativo
del explorador
ble que te ha llamado la atención con
fuerza es necesario recordar que se
nutre de internet y por ello puede dar
resultados con sesgos lo que hace que
sea una gran herramienta pero que
requiere revisiones humanas cabe
recordar que ante la presión por el
éxito de esta Inteligencia artificial
Google ya anunció que lanzará un
servicio conversacional similar que será
aprobado por un grupo selecto y lanzado
ampliamente para finales de este año
compañías chinas e incluso meta tienen
planes similares
vamos ahora hasta España puntualmente al
hospital valdebron de Barcelona que va a
empezar a probar una técnica que de
resultar exitosa podría ser
Revolucionaria se trata de un
medicamento pediátrico impreso en 3D
cuya eficacia tolerabilidad y nivel de
aceptación serán testeados la mayor
Innovación consiste en que la impresión
3D permite elaborar medicamentos con
dosis personalizadas del principio
activo lo que evita errores de
administración hemos diseñado un ensayo
clínico en el cual vamos a utilizar una
fórmula estándar para los pacientes
pediátricos es una fórmula líquida y
vamos a comparar el resultado con una
fórmula preparada con impresión 3D como
novedad aportamos que preparamos la
dosis que necesita el paciente de manera
individualizada es una dosis
personalizada también podemos
Modificar el sabor el olor las
características organoléticas para que
sea más por los pacientes pediátricos se
trata del primer ensayo clínico con un
fármaco impreso en 3D en el ámbito
pediátrico en Europa y la impresión 3D
permite que los medicamentos sean
elaborados en forma semi sólida y
masticable como una especie de gomita
que cuenta con el principio activo y
excipientes adecuados las dosis
personalizadas son clave porque hasta
ahora por ejemplo con un jarabe o una
pastilla los padres deben dosificar de
acuerdo con el peso del niño algo que no
sería necesario con esta Innovación
vamos a incluir 30 pacientes Ese es el
diseño de nuestro ensayo y Las edades
irán a partir de los seis años entre los
6 y los 18 años de edad porque son
comprimidos que tienen que o masticarse
o bien tienen que tragarse por tanto la
población de menor edad no puede
participar porque debería seguir tomando
la fórmula estándar que es una fórmula
líquida el ensayo está diseñado para
realizarse dentro de los hospitales y
para que en un principio la tecnología
de impresión 3D disponible en centros de
salud no obstante los responsables
aseguran que en un futuro será esencial
que las farmacias puedan contar con este
tipo de tecnología Pues podría aplicarse
a todos los medicamentos que no se vean
afectados por cambios de temperatura
volvemos a Estados Unidos para finalizar
este espacio porque científicos de la
Universidad de Yale crearon un robot que
se asemeja a una tortuga está inspirado
en tortugas tanto marítimas como
terrestres las particulares patas del
artefacto se adaptan se adaptan su forma
y rigidez dependiendo del ambiente se
llama anfibios robotic turtle o Art y
según sus responsables sería clave en el
monitoreo de aguas profundas
como parte de nuestra estrategia de
diseño reemplazamos las patas del robot
que generalmente se hacen con materiales
fijos por materiales que cambian de
forma Así permitimos que el robot
modifique la forma de sus extremidades
dependiendo de los diferentes ambientes
creo que puede ayudar en trabajos de
monitoreo ambiental por ejemplo de un
sistema de estuario donde el robot
Tendría que ir entre parches de tierra y
parches de agua y hacer la transición de
un lado a otro para inspeccionar y tomar
datos otro caso de uso potencial es por
ejemplo el apoyo a los buceadores el
robot podría transportar materiales o
herramientas desde la tierra a un sitio
de trabajo bajo el agua
así finalizamos este espacio a ustedes
Les agradecemos su sintonía les
recordamos que pueden ampliar todo
nuestro contenido en la web France 24
punto com
[Música]